alright so I'm going to talk about
popular conjectures which most of you
have seen which popular conjectures I
mean and dynamic problem problems and
what's a dynamic problem you have some
function you want to compute and you're
given an input on this function you
compute this it compute the result and
now one at a time people start giving
you updates to the input so this bit
change that be changed and while they're
doing these updates they can also ask
your queries what is the output of the
function right now okay and this is a
dynamic problem and one trivial way to
solve dynamic problems is to recompute
the function from scratch every time a
bit changes you recomputed or you can
even or you can recompute a query time
and the central question of dynamic
algorithms is when can you do better
when can you substantially improve on
the brute force sort of way of
recomputing everything from scratch and
for on what problems you can save
substantially so let me begin with a
plan so the plan is going to be I'll
give you some overview of various little
conditional lower bounds with proven and
then I'll show you again some very
simple proofs and I'll Indiana talk a
little bit about recent developments and
if we still have time about open
problems which luxury will we'll see
okay so here's one of the interesting
dynamic problems your input is a graph
and your updates are added and removed
edges the query I want to answer is for
these special vertices s and T are they
connected in the current graph there's
variants of the problem sometimes you
allow the query can ask for different
pairs S&T so they can say for this as in
tier they connected in the current graph
again the trivial update time is order
em then
veggies because after each update or
query you could just check whether
something connected and so on and one of
the big successes of dynamic algorithms
is to show that actually you don't have
to do or damn you can do Polly
logarithmic in fact roughly log M time /
update and this is our actually very
nice because there's also sell probe
lower bound up a trashcan domain they
show that log M is necessary in the sale
pro model okay this is a big success now
consider the directed version of this
problem now instead of an undirected
graph you have directed graph again you
can add and remove edges as the updates
and there's two different queries maybe
I want to answer one of them is just
like in the previous slide are to fix
vertices s and T can you reach t from s
and the other version is you just fix
one vertex s and you want to know in the
current graph how many vertices can you
reach from us we call that problem
number SSR anyway number of reachable
notes ok so again the trivial thing is
you recompute what you want to answer in
order n time you can save something if
you if your graph is dense enough and
you use matrix multiplication but the
best cell probe lower bounds we have is
are still logarithmic okay so there's a
huge gap between what we can do and what
we can prove and so this is not great
and we want to do something about this
and all right this happens for many
problems you can build a huge list here
this is some sample so besides reach
ability maybe you want to maintain the
number the strongly strongly connected
components of a graph maybe you just
want to know their number maybe you want
to know if the number is bigger than two
okay its various variants of this
maximum matching maybe you want to know
the size of the maximum matching maybe
you want to know some approximate
matching then there's a connectivity
problem just like on the first live
graph connectivity you want to know when
u and v are connected but now your
updates are not edge edge insertions and
deletions instead the the updates are
not the insertions and deletions here
the best upper bounds are or their
mordrem if you want to approximate the
diameter say I tell you give me four
thirds approximation of the diameter and
of a graph underage insertions and
deletions the best thing we know how to
do is compute all pair shortest paths
after each update this is crazy it
should sound crazy too why why should we
have to do all this work after every
update I don't know but the best lower
bounds are get lucky huge huge
difference so today I'm going to talk
about how assuming various conjectures
that we've seen so far you can actually
prove some tight lower bounds for these
problems okay so let me start with a
paper by petrushka from stock 2010 he
considered the 3-sum problem which I
define in the first lecture so here
you're given an integers you want to
know if three of them some 20 we have a
simple and squared time algorithm and
there is a conjecture 3sum conjecture
they can't do much better so n to the 2
minus epsilon 4 epsilon greater than 0
it's probably not possible if you see on
this conjecture but trash because paper
shows that you can show you can show
some polynomial lower bound of the
update time for problems such as the
ones I mentioned on the first light for
the directed rich ability problem for
how many nodes can you reach from a
source and for the undirected
connectivity problem when you have note
updates and many other problems so this
said that no Polly low-grade
makeup date times are possible if you
believe threesome so you have to pay
some polynomial time every time you do
an update ok so then two papers looked
at Petrobras paper try to optimize the
parameters to see if you could push this
M today to something more meaningful and
we got em to the one-third so it gets a
threesome lower bound for the update
time for all these problems which is
roughly into the one-third and for some
reason some technical reason we couldn't
be on we couldn't go beyond them to the
one-third and so we're kind of stuck so
then we thought well maybe threesome is
not the right problem to reduce from
maybe one of our other cool conjectures
could explain why these problems are
difficult
okay so then let's consider this
combinatorial boolean matrix
multiplication conjecture that there is
no went to the 2.99 algorithm for
boolean matrix multiplication so
combinatorial is not well defined and so
on but let's let's consider this and if
we prove some lower bounds for this
problem it will mean that any algorithm
would have to use some form of fast
matrix multiplication if you assume this
conjecture then all these problems
require m or the Omega oven time /
update if you if you don't use class
matrix multiplication okay so now we're
in this very nice setting except we're
losing something because of the
combinatorial business okay however a
follow-up paper by hand single croninger
nano in cars are in Iraq whose names are
hopefully I pronounce properly some of
them are here they show that actually if
you assume a different conjecture there
is not about a competitor oh hell girdim
then these most of these lower bounds
also called for for non combinatorial
algorithms as well so let me define this
problem in the conjecture so the online
matrix vector problem is given an n-by-n
boolean matrix and let's say n boolean
vectors that are given in an online
fashion so you get v1 v2 and so on then
after the moment you get VI you have to
output the product of a with VI okay and
you have to do this for all of them and
so clearly every time you get a VI you
can also do the product in n squared
time so you could do you can solve this
problem in n squared worst-case time /
update / query vector Ryan in 2007 said
well let's preprocess a matrix we pay
just a little bit and to the epsilon
over head over the size of the matrix
and then after you do
now the products take n squared of a log
squared time instead of n squared and
this is worst-case time every time you
do a matrix vector product you get some
savings over N squared okay but then why
can we just do enter the 1.9 and we
don't know what if we relax this
worst-case so it's now amortized so
sometimes the matrix vector products
could take a long time but on average
maybe they will take very little time
okay so and again even if we relax this
condition the worst case condition we
don't know how to do better than
essentially n squared so this motivated
this conjecture the the conjectures that
this this problem requires essentially n
squared ever touch time and notice that
so if you believe that boolean matrix
multiplication doesn't have any less
than n cubed organists you believe this
one this one says nothing about
combinatorial algorithms but it allows
you to prove basically the same sort of
results that the boolean matrix
multiplication problem allowed us to do
because because the way we did things
anyway we were we were solving boolean
matrix multiplication by just solving
matrix vector multiplications so if so
then many of the lower bounds transfer
okay so there were attempts to prove
this conjecture so we a recent attempt
was to show a lower bound in the cell
probe model here you fix a very large
finite field and end some space usage s
of your data structure and then you can
show the following lower bound and log
of the size of the field times N squared
this is only meaningful when the size of
the field is large so you can get
something that's super linear in it okay
but it's not it's not what we want
what is getting there yes claussen grown
wound and Larson yes only when the
spaces with you this is the
instantiation of the result when the
space is linear they have a more
complicated expression for arbitrary
space but the the bound is most
meaningful for this scenario otherwise
it's much more even represent a matrix
this is overhead on top of the matrix
you can store the matrix and then on top
of it you good okay all right so this is
the online matrix vector problem in a
conjecture and now what we can do we can
add this conjecture too many of these
problems here and now we get M&M and
this is this is great except now we add
a new conjecture good so now it all
looks good but what about this bizarre
issue here if we want to approximate the
diameter we the best algorithm we know
is just to recompute all pair shortest
path from scratch and here we only get
an linear or may go Ven lower bound and
so maybe there's a completely different
conjecture that explains this okay this
motivates bringing or strong radiation
orthogonal vectors to the dynamic world
so here let me just recap again in case
you weren't here the previous few talks
strong eth says that there's some for
every epsilon there's a k such a case
that can't be solved in 2 minus epsilon
to the end time and orthogonal vector
says if you're given a set of n vectors
of Dimension Data slightly put a super
league written
you can't solve it in less than n
squared primer session probably a lot
palio the dimension okay see you mean
this is true now you can prove the
following you can prove that these
problems require an Omega vent i'm just
like these conjuncture said and on top
of that approximating the diameter
better than four thirds this is what
this means here requires on my
government r / update so we can prove
pretty strong lower bounds just assuming
for this cottage now I actually show you
the proof of this in a bit it's not too
bad okay right yes five conjectures they
still independent as far as we know and
there's some so they're past probably
may be independent and there's some
attempts to proving this I go close get
close to there yeah they could be
independent and actually at the end of
the talk I'll show you that there's a
conjecture that that is strictly most
more believable than all of them that
also implies all these things and that's
uh basically it's a conjecture that the
conjecture is that at least one of them
is true so it's okay you see all right
so the point of all of this is that
sometimes different conjectures are
better for explaining different barriers
and often it what you have to do is look
at your problem and sort of think what
does it structurally resemble and then
if once you figure that out it's usually
not too bad in finding the reduction but
the tricky part is figuring out which of
these conjectures you can use and
sometimes we you have to have a new
conjecture okay now besides these
problems there's various other problems
that we can't prove lower bounced two in
particular some weighted problems and so
then we can assume the all pair shortest
paths conjecture there
we say that all pair shortest paths
cannot be solved in n to the 3 minus
epsilon time for any epsilon that's a
constant bigger than 0 and now if you
assume this you can add more problems to
list for example you can add the problem
where you're given to fix notes smt and
you do edge updates and you want to know
what is the current distance between S&T
let's set and all pair shortest paths is
that this problem and also the
maintaining and maximum weight matching
in a graph require and square time for
update and the true of your arguments
for both these problems running a square
time for dense graphs so so that's so
now again different conjectures are
better for explaining different things
we didn't know originally whether you
can prove such a result from strong eth
and the other problems but now i know a
little bit more so we'll get to that
later ok questions at this point
yes so the show's past rejection is for
din scripts right yes so I love sweeping
a little bit under director actually
okay this M is n for sparse graphs this
N squared is for dense graphs okay so
you cannot only really prove this for
dense graphs so it doesn't say if you
can do this slightly better form sparse
graphs no I'm sweeping something under
the rug but it's close to what what is
true you're sure this happens actually
yes yes you can but the reductions have
to change the way we have them because
we go yeah we can we can have a
conjecture for sparse graphs that all
patients pass requires omega n time for
aggressive well okay I meant to the 1
minus epsilon 4 0 epsilon but with the
reductions we have will be more
complicated because for as we saw two
lectures ago for dense graphs we can say
that all pair shortest path is
equivalent to a negative triangle which
is a very simple problem to reduce from
but for sparse graphs we don't have such
a simple problem which makes things
harder
alright so we finished the overview and
what I'll do now is I'll give you very
very short and simple proofs it'll be
very similar to what we've seen before
except in a dynamic something and
hopefully you see how how these proofs
usually go and then we'll get into the
recent developments okay so let's
revisit this problem of single source
searchability will consider the version
where you're given a graph and a fixed
node s and you want to maintain the
number of reachable notes from s and you
can insert and delete edges again the
trivial algorithm stairs and whenever an
edge is inserted or deleted you just
recompute the rich ability set from us
in order n time if you assume the online
matrix vector multiplication conjecture
you can prove an Omega square root of a
matar update time and we show that under
strong eth n orthogonal vectors this
problem can be solved in this much time
and m to the 1 minus epsilon times where
it's an almost bite load up
here's how the reduction would go this
is the outline and then I'll give it the
extra thing so you're given the
orthogonal vectors let's assume we split
we'll just have two copies of the set
and now we want to find a vector here in
a vector here there are polymer so now
we will build some instance of this
dynamic problem and this instance will
have n times d edges G is the dimension
n is the number of vectors this minion
edges and nodes so it's very sparse the
number of updates will perform it will
be roughly the same as the number of
nodes and edges and the same holds for a
number of queries suppose we had an
amortized em to the point 9 update and
query time then we plug in ND over here
adi essentially goes into this tilter
and we get that we can perform order ND
updates and queries in n to the 1.9 time
and then because of the weight reduction
go went we get the orthogonal vectors
it's in hand to the 1.9 time so this is
the the way we'll do it now let me show
you how we do it all right so here the
vector instance will build this graph
these are nodes corresponding to the
dimensions of the vectors you want to
deep we have a single source s which
will be the source for our rich ability
questions and here we have these n nodes
the correspond to the vectors will
hardwire the static part so we'll first
of all people will add these this is the
initial initial input given to the
problem so what we'll do here is we'll
put an edge from a dimension note I
let's say two vector note here if the
vector is one in that dimension so here
this this corresponds to the blue edges
whenever bi is one with in dimension J
would put an edge there okay and the
edges go from left to right
okay so this part would be static we
won't be changing it the only thing we
will do is will add edges here and
remove the magic a so here's how we add
and remove edges for every vector when
it's time to ask query about it at each
step will ask a query whether there's
any vector orthogonal to AI okay so
whenever a I comes in to be written to
ask about we'll put an edge between s
and a dimension if AI is one in that
dimension okay and then after we insert
all these D edges at most D edges will
make a query to ask how many nodes are
reachable from s okay then you have this
observation and I've seen before s
cannot reach some vector B if and only
if AI and beer at all now and then what
do we do well we know what then how many
nodes will be reachable if the vectors
are not orthogonal and this will be so
you can reach D vectors the dimension at
most so the number of ones in eight is
the number of edges here and you can
reach this many loads over here and n is
all these if you can reach fewer than n
plus the number of ones and a then
definitely there's a toga no vector to
AI and so you check this condition and
then your output yes if you get fewer
than what you expected if you didn't if
it says that there's exactly this menu
reachable note then you remove these
blue edges and move on to the next day I
then you cover all of the AIS and this
is the entire algorithm it's again very
simple okay
the number of edges is n times the
dimension it most the number of updates
is the sum of the number of edges okay
and so what you get is ND updates and d
query of any queries and ND notes that's
exactly what we want it and it should
reduce its orthogonal vectors to this
problem in kind of a trivial way and
this graph is always very sparse okay so
with additional gadgets and some other
trick erations you can improve lower
bounds for strongly connected components
even in the case when you want to know
if the number number is more than two
again you can you can prove tight lower
bounds and drag the connected you know
the updates and so on okay so you know
most of these reductions are not too
hard they just do what we just did okay
so the next thing I'll show you a
slightly different reduction that use a
lower bound for diameter ok so the
dynamic day I'm under problem you're
given an undirected graph you add or
remove edges and the query is what is
the current dynamic we have upper bounds
the upper bounds are then I yvonne's RM
n / update you can do amortized n square
time I feel a little bit more clever but
when when the graph is parse this is to
MN very good so what we showed is that
if you assume that strong eth holds it's
not it's not a reduction form orthogonal
vectors by the way just from strong a
cage then even approximated the diameter
with four within a four thurs minus
epsilon factor will give you something
interesting even when the graph is
sparse and you have to it will take n
square time birthday
okay the previous type of reduction
wouldn't work because we couldn't prove
such strong update times you can only
prove n so we did something different so
if you look back at what Ryan's paper
does when it reduces strong eth two
orthogonal vectors there's no reason to
reduce it to two orthogonal vectors you
could reduce it to three orthogonal
vectors instead so now orthogonality
means now when you take three vectors
they cannot all be one in any coordinate
so here's the distance three sets of
vectors you want to find three vectors
that are not there are mutually
orthogonal so and what we do is we take
this and reduce it to dynamic diameter
and ryans we will carry over ryan's
proof that i showed you what you will
get is that if you can solve this whole
problem faster than n cubed time then
start at age fails ok
ok so the outline of the reduction is
will be constructing graph again on ND
nodes and edges and will do ND updates
and queries but now if we're fighting
against cubic time instead of quadratic
so if we get a quadratic better than
quadratic amortized update time and you
plug it is Indian you get into the 2.9
time algorithm for 30 orthogonal vectors
so the reduction will be a little bit
similar so what we do is for all the
vectors in the set a we put notes all
the vectors of the set B we put notes
and we put two copies of the coordinates
coordinate notes these edges is the same
as in the previous reduction there's an
edge between a coordinate I and a vector
B if B is one in the coordinate same
holds here there's a vector between a
and J if a is one and coordinate J ok
and so far the diameter is infinity we
haven't added anything these edges will
be static will won't be doing anything
to them but we'll be adding and removing
edges in here ok the number of nodes is
n plus D the number of edges in it is
roughly n times d ok so now the way the
updates work whenever one of each stage
will have a vector and set C and now
whenever the vector C I comes in we're
going to put a matching between the
copies of the nodes the copies of the
coordinates where this vector is one
okay so now we have a matching here
after we put this matching in there
we'll ask the diameter query okay
there's an observation that the distance
between an a node and the bean load is
strictly more than three if and only if
the three vectors are polymer ok so the
diameter will be strictly more than
three you that happens ok so we query is
the diameter bigger than three if it
says yes then we output yes otherwise if
we remove all the edges we insert it
here is the most D of them and we move
on to the next CI if there's ever an
orthogonal triple we will catch it we
only perform n times d updates
and the graph is small and this this
concludes the reduction again very very
simple but because we started from
something that's not orthogonal vectors
we proved the higher lower bound it's
not always possible but for this problem
it is it's really really expressive
so here's a summary of this part of the
talk we can get some very high
conditional lower bounds for fundamental
problems and after your identify the
conjecture it's often not too hard and
yes I think some of these reductions are
so simple you can present them in
courses so good motivation to this so
here we're back at the plan we finished
a lot of floor weekend so I'll tell you
a little bit about some recent things
we've been proving and if we have more
time ago get into open problems
questions yes see look all the lower
bounds like that you're giving don't use
the full power of dynamics problem
they're all about you have some function
of x and y and you want to evaluate it
1x and many wise yes yes that is true
we're not exploiting the full power and
but this also gives us some something
that gives us that we can prove lower
bounds for partially dynamic algorithms
that are good in the worst case but
there's some recent work that was able
to use a little bit more of the power so
there besides our remote adding and
removing the edges like this so this is
the work by Seth Petty and co-author so
they they also increase the graph as
they go along and they did they reuse
the information in a more clever way and
they're able to prove stronger lower
bounds so it's a great question we are
not we could be getting much better
things if we use the full power of
dynamic algorithms
so so there is this other conjecture
which is that well maybe you don't
believe that all of these are true but
maybe you believe that at least one of
these conjectures is true that either
stronger th holds or 3some requires in
square time or open space requires and
keep time so suppose that either one of
these is true then all of a sudden you
can still prove these lower bounds so
all of these problems have linear lower
bounds before we could improve any
connection between all pairs shortest
paths in these problems but now we can
prove a lower bound of n / update so new
new techniques we have okay this
threesome lower bound they used to be m
to the one-third became n so now we have
even more reason to believe that these
dynamic problems are difficult because
now you only have to believe that one of
the conjectures and we think that these
conjectures are probably unrelated okay
okay so how would you prove such a thing
what we did it is we found
simple-looking problems that you can
reduce all these problems too in this in
the sense that if you have an end to the
2.9 algorithm of 23 10 to the 3 minus
epsilon our algorithm for any one of
these and all these problems has faster
algorithms and the nice thing is that
okay we could have just proven this
result it would have been interesting
but now we can also reduce these simple
problems to dynamic problems and also
some long dynamic problems and these
these the conjecture at least one of
these can problems is hard implies that
dynamic coachability requires
essentially in time / update and this
funny thing which I have to define
against over there
it's max flow except now you're given
two sets of nodes SNT you can think of
them as being size square root of N and
I want to know for every pair of an OD
national no deity what's the max flow
between them seems like maybe these
wonderful max flow techniques that
people have been developing maybe could
solve this problem but what we show is
that if you believe they're at least one
of these conjectures is true then this
this problem requires them to the 1.5 x
given in grass yeah so this time
previously when you're doing strong eth
you were doing it by orthogonal vectors
you have to use the strongly cage
directly here yeah so that this is
something interesting and we didn't
these we can't reduce orthogonal vectors
to these problems but the problem I just
showed you three orthogonal vectors you
can so reduce this to three orthogonal
vectors to this problem
okay i'll define the problems now the
first one is as follows the problem on a
graph with colors and on the notes you
have a node graph on n nodes and squared
edges and you want to know is there
triple of colors so so that there's at
least Delta triangles connecting these
colors with this colors now what's Delta
if Delta is one we can solve this
problem then the problem becomes is
there triple of colors so that there's
at least one triangle which is
equivalent to asking is there try and go
in a graph so we can solve that problem
with triangle detection becomes n to the
Omega if they'll take goes to 0 you can
still do something but it's it's the
runtime becomes higher as Delta
approaches login we don't know how to do
better than n cubed and in fact if you
could do into the 3 minus epsilon in the
regime when Delta is log in then all
three conjectures are false
this is that this is a static problem
this is now static problem yes there are
no color scale is not playing a role no
doesn't know you could put it in there
but it's roughly n this is a real
proportional to the number of nodes so
this is 0 this is the next slide good
question when Delta is 2 3 and so on you
can always get an algorithms it's better
than n cubed and we can define design an
algorithm with exponent that's roughly
this much depending a delta this is
assuming Omega 2 Omega is not too then
something else happens here but it's
always sub-q bukh we also get a lower
bound and they're all three conjectures
that's super quadratic okay and they
meet sort of in the limit and it says
that there's these problems parametrized
by the number of triangles you want
whose complexity somewhere in here yeah
I sort of interesting so what do you
mean by the Lord oh this is under these
today under the conjecture it's not an
unconditional urban assumes that at
least one of the three conjectures is
true and then then this holds now if you
if you want to have a very easy to
describe problem that requires a certain
amount of time you can pick one of these
okay so there's this other problem with
a very poorly chosen name but we were
under a deadline pressure that we
couldn't change it okay so so strong go
collection again you're given a graph
with note colors and you want to know is
there some triple that has no triangles
there in other words the do the
triangles collect all the triples of
colors okay that's why its collection
okay maybe it's collecting triangles I
don't know we can have some suggestions
about how to rename it okay so now this
problem again just like the previous one
you can try out ripples of loads and
resolve it in n cube time but if you
could do substantially better so enter
the epsilon better then again you can
defeat off all three conjectures trying
different then you really wanted color
to appear in the pyro and watch I know
it's a lots of condition okay yeah maybe
maybe if we short on it thing okay so
okay triangle collection okay so and if
we assume if we use this triangle
collection problem we can prove these
lower bounds here that I mentioned
before we didn't use matching triangles
which is strange but we use the subject
problem it's more it's easier to use in
reductions
so why are these problems hard they'll
give you a little bit of snapshot of the
proof of one of them so the way we
reduce all these problems to these
simple looking triangle problems is we
go through intermediate steps so strong
eth we solve the three orthogonal
vectors problem i will reduce this one
to both these problems for these three
salmon all pair shortest paths we
actually have a lot of the work done for
us so patrasche co had a nice reduction
from threesome to convolution prison
which is a problem i'm not going to
define and we had this reduction to
negative triangle in it in 20 in 2009
2010 Ryan and I reduce both these
problems to problem called zero triangle
and zero triangle is given a graph on n
nodes you want to know what weights on
the edges you want to know if there's
triangle with weight some exactly zero
okay so some papers later on looked at
this problem called its love triangle
but I'm not okay I'm not a big fan of
that name okay so zero triangle and then
we took these two problems or develop
some new reductions to prove this if you
look at the reductions probably the more
interesting one is this one here it
takes a problem that has weights on the
edges there could be polynomially big
and produces problems they have no
weights
ok so again the it's roughly believed
that this this problem is hard because
these ways can be so big and how are you
going to ever solve it if the weights
are very small you there is a sub cubic
algorithm but when they're when they're
big we don't have techniques to handle
it but our reduction kills the weights
and replaces them with these colors and
I'll tell you how we do this roughly so
just some intuition so the naive attempt
so it's not that name but it's a simple
attempt to do this is to create a gadget
for every edge with some weight and
instead of having an edge we're going to
replace all the nodes with some more
notes here you can think of the nodes
right now representing the weights in
the graph and then you have other nodes
here for node Y again representing the
weights in the graph ok this won't work
yet because there's a lot of weights but
this just hang on a moment then if we
did this we could replace an edge of
weight W with an edge from every X to a
y such that X plus the weight is why so
if we did that you get that a 0-0
triangle will be represented by triangle
work we do that if we'd if this were to
work right we could just color all the
nodes corresponding to a particular
vertex X with glue or discolor ups or
vertex you with its call over this color
will just be the name of the vertex you
now this is wonderful except the graph
becomes enormous we started with a graph
on their nose and then we replaced every
node with nodes corresponding to the
weights but the way it can be in the
range minus sent to the CNN to the sefer
and you put any constancy so what are
you going to do luckily there was this
nice paper which had a wonderful name ok
by a mere Kevin Louie and Ryan in easter
2014 they looked at the threesome
problem and they showed that in that
case you can you can sort of reduce
threesome to a different version of
threesome in where instead of integers
now you have vectors and the in the
coordinates the vectors are very have
very small integers and the dimension is
also very small so now it's some version
of threesome we're given a set of these
short vectors with do with a range in
the coordinates very small and you want
to know if there's three vector just
mutually some to some target it can be
zero or some other vector okay so they
were able to get rid of the polynomial
size integers with some very small ones
by making it into vectors hello we
noticed that we can actually not really
but you can fix up this gadget so that
all of a sudden you translate these
vectors in 2d triangles and D is this
dimension here ok and I don't have time
to do this but I can flash the slide if
you want
yes actually this Chinese remainder or
guilt a world how it's done ah Brian do
you want to tell tell them how it's been
since you're an author oh well want me
to think about it you split the split
the so think of the numbers is like C
log n bit stream yeah you split the
number into according to slide order log
n over log in pieces then you well then
we guess all the carries but like from
one piece to the next piece there's only
three numbers being some so the number
of carries is there's some constant
right and right and so then within each
piece it's like only order to log in
click possible possible numbers where
does the numbers are like law order log
n bits link yeah I think you could use
Chinese your main ring to it so i think
there's no loss enough though that's all
here's a statement or what they proved
okay for any choice of the dimension d
constant c and n number of integers you
can map the integers from minus n to the
c n to the c to some set of vectors with
whenever d is cost in this culture which
are which map so every integers map to a
bunch of vectors the dimension of the
vector is d and every vector has entries
in n to the C or D roughly sighs and
then you preserve this property that
threesomes map to vector threesomes and
then what we did is we we build a graph
for every choice of these T to dollar D
vectors and and the graph will follow
the same gadget reburning I'm not sure
if I have enough time to cover it so
I'll cover it if only if people are
interested in is who is interested in
well okay not enough to do this whole
thing talk to me after that okay okay so
i'll spend just a few minutes on what's
next for this approach this was urgent
is supposed to be two talks but I just
sort of merge them into one it used to
be three to thirty minute talks alright
so the first thing is we need a better
understanding with the conjectures
basically how do they relate to each
other can we get rid of some of them can
we actually refute them that would be
great okay this one was supposed to fade
okay then maybe we want to classify some
more problems here's some unclassified
problems what about that match the
maximum matching in the static case can
we improve any any lower bound on it the
current best algorithm even for
bipartite metric is m to the 10 / 7 it's
not linear can we prove anything super
linear for this I don't know maybe it
can be done in linear time what about
linear programming it seems like such an
expressive problem can we prove any
interesting lower bound I suspect this
probably not possible but maybe you
could try it i can rewrite a small
linear program for token of vectors of
threesome maybe you could use there's
these nice lower bounds on the size of
the near programs for problems so maybe
you could show that these problems don't
have such small linear programs or maybe
you could write one and that would be
interesting recently we decided what if
instead of just these conjectures let's
focus on conjecture 4k click and we
prove some stuff about it so if you
believe that so there is an end to the
omega k / 3 algorithm which is roughly
this much for key click if you believe
this is optimal of a sudden you prove
out there that other problems are hard
so this basically means that if you
improve on their running time you didn't
prove on this sort of long-standing
upper bound for cake cake which would be
very interesting I think it would be
nice to approval it's a very simple
algorithm
okay here's two problems that we can
reduce k click to one is a context-free
grammar parsing and given a constant
context-free grammar fixed size and some
string you want to know if the string
can be derived from the grammar and
there is an N cubed algorithm Leslie
Valley and show the name to do make the
time algorithm actually and we show that
actually feeling proven entity Omega for
Constance ties grammars then Kiki has
faster algorithms so before lillian lee
had shown that and this is true when the
grammars can be very big in terms of
this length of the string but now we
showed it even for the constant cases
true so so this is just to show you that
k click implies interesting things for
very diverse looking problems here's
another one RNA folding you have a
string from a biological application
let's say and you want to find a
matching so see matches G&A Majesty but
see doesn't match anything else and it
doesn't match anything else and you have
to draw these matching edges on top so
that you don't get any crosses its
equivalent to having a bunch of balanced
parentheses but there's parenthesis of
different types okay and we show that
that there's a enter dealmaker lower
bound for this believe if you believe
there are k click conjecture and
interesting enough these best algunos
here cubic i think they should be
entered a mega but we don't have a proof
so a mere had these slides house-elves I
think it's good for this community to we
had these so there's a reason why you
might believe this conjecture saran has
an algorithm for max cut and many other
two CSPs that could be so faster if you
had faster algorithms for key click you
use the faster algorithm for triangle
but you could do it with k click so
there's a connection between
the algorithms here the fur RNA for the
problems for our RNA folding and so on
and these problems in exponential time
like Max Cup so if you believe the max
cut doesn't have a faster algorithm
DeLoreans then you should believe that
RNA folding cannot be soaked faster than
data Jamaica time zone okay and in the
spirit we would like more connections to
exact algorithms and by exact algorithms
I mean for hard problems ok so we had
these nice reductions from CNN fassett
orthogonal vectors and problems in
quadratic time you could think of these
reductions from k click as things
relating max cut another co 2 tsps do
this to these two problems what if you
pick your favorite NP complete problem
for which we have a certain exact
running time that sort of long standing
what can you prove about problems in the
lower class maybe again you can
formulate various conjectures here that
tsp requires and and 2 to the N time and
so on and you can just try to bring it
down to some interesting problems that
have been studied with in porn on your
time ok and then you could bring this
approach up to the paulino to the the
heart problems and try to really relate
them there has already been some work
about on this so there's a work relating
set covering Steiner Chi but you can go
on you can go on with all these others
and try to say that they required to the
end time if and only if all of them do
or maybe there's some other thing you
could do in this world ok and
experimental tractability we had
wonderful talks about this so in fpt
people care whether problem can be
solved in F of K times poly n time where
K is a parameter natural to the problem
and n is the input size why don't we
just bring this down to pull the
polynomial
world why do we have to constrain
ourselves to exponential time solvable
problems why don't we just do it in the
and for n square type problems maybe
there's parameters for which n squared
time hard problems can be solved in
linear time times F of K this would be
great and we have some example of this
again diameter I seem to like diameter
okay so we have diameters sparse grass
again we saw we have no sub quadratic
algorithm for it under strong eth but
let's say the graph is special and has
small tree with maybe we can do better
we show well yes you can if the tree
with its more you can get n to the 1
plus little 1 x 2 to the K log K okay
this is good for constant tree with
refined have a lower bound under
orthogonal vectors and strong eth if you
could do to to the little of K times n
to the 1.9 then strong eth fails so
these are not tight but it's it's sort
of a nice example of how you could bring
this down to the polynomial time world
yeah you look like your hair equations
right but say two to the key and to the
1.9 it doesn't refute anything ah yeah
if you had tits decay not to do the
little of k then it doesn't refute
anything but we just couldn't bring this
algorithm down I couldn't get rid of
this Loki would have been nice but yeah
so why not just to do it for lower
problems just thinking we would love to
have linear time in NY not mean ok and
finally hardness of approximation again
I mentioned this before edit distance
has an ear linear time poly logarithmic
approximation scheme maybe there's some
PCP ta da problem as it seems like a
very different task but maybe there is a
way to bring that down to the lower
polynomial time world and try to show
some some gap in play amplification here
too so we have these reductions that
seem to only care about a plus one
difference between the answers but maybe
looking amplified in some nice way we
don't know how to do that yet let's
you mentioned about Louisville foot in
your programming but what is known for
about Oh linear programming upper bounds
so there has been some recent very nice
work on problems of this type using
gradient descent that are so polynomial
so for even like just for max flow you
can get better than what you expect but
these problems have much higher running
time than N squared and cubed I think
it's a four max flow I think is you
solve root n linear systems and
variables or something like that so a
linear systems often taken to their mega
time so you might get into D Omega plus
a half so it's more than this stuff here
but but in any case why not just get an
N squared lower bar and to the 1.5 we're
not just something something non trivial
and we don't know how to build small
linear programs out of the conjectures
the way we have right now maybe it's not
possible
you showed us of now in the last four
days a bunch of conjectures and I think
all of the constructions you showed us
if you remember where deterministic
right yes are there examples where
that's randomized and we would like to
have a deterministic because then we had
to believe less so some of the things
involving threesome were involved some
randomized caching yeah so some of these
involve some sort of randomization
conjecture down to numbers in the yeah
that one is also random okay I don't
know how to do that arrest if we order
into 3sum conjecture deterministic leads
are having a small small numbers I
window how to read and rehash different
cute that's right so again a very good
point about threesome and it's hashing
down the making the numbers down to the
interval minus n keep thank you that's
randomized as far as we know
thanks